hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
towards the end of the first essay of
his genealogy of morals friedrich
nietzsche
is going to set out this symbol
as he calls it of rome versus judea
and when you read through this he says
you know we're coming to this by way of
conclusion
these two opposing values good and bad
good and evil have been engaged in a
fearful struggle on earth
for thousands of years and then he says
though the latter value that is good
versus evil
has certainly been on top for a long
time there are still places where the
struggle is as yet
undecided and he's got an interesting
suggestion here he says
and this is going to be followed out in
the later chapters one might even say
it's risen ever higher and thus become
more profound and spiritual
so that today there's no more decisive
mark of a higher nature
than of being divided in this sense and
a genuine battleground of these two
opposed values and so you know there's a
suggestion there that
we don't want to just endorse the one or
just endorse
the other in a way
it's a problem that's set before the
people who are
maybe even a higher not synthesis but a
battleground as he says between them
and then he engages in some pretty clear
you know typology essentializing
that is to some degree it's
understandable but also
weakens the the the sort of claims that
he's making
in the work and not just because he's
being anti-semitic in
a typical nietzschean way here where he
doesn't like other anti-semites and
as kaufman actually points out in a
a note here he says having said things
that can easily be construed as
grist to the mill of the german
anti-semites nietzsche goes out of his
way
as usual to express his admiration for
the jews and his is disdain
for the germans he's he's expressing
admiration for the jews
by calling them a first-rate priestly
nation of resentment par excellence so i
don't really think that's that's calling
them
you know it's not extolling them or
anything like that
and what we've got here is it could be
criticized from that perspective but i
think we could actually put that aside
enough people have made criticisms
in in that vein and say nietzsche is not
actually remaining
true to his own insights here about the
important roles
played by these valuations and how this
isn't quite so simple
and and we're going to see this
reflected in the second and third essays
which are
dealing with with a lot of other
phenomena so let's just follow along and
see what nature says and then we can say
whether we
think that it holds water or not so
there's this clash of valuations
good versus bad right the noble versus
the common the original evaluation
and then we have the trans-evaluated
good versus evil
where the people who are defining
themselves as good are doing so
negatively by not being evil
like the strong or or the you know
beasts of
prey any of that sort of thing they're
nice they're kind
and you could say okay well who is this
representing in a way the common people
the people who are also filled with
resentment the priest the priestly
figure although the priest is coming out
of the aristocracy
and does remain kind of a third a third
figure a third approach in
things as well and then nietzsche
reduces things to a binary and it's it's
kind of interesting instead of
athens versus jerusalem he does bring up
tertullian
in here uh it's going to be rome versus
judea and
well let's let's lay out what he says
and then we'll think about how plausible
it is so he says let's let's go to it
the symbol of this struggle inscribed in
letters legible across all human history
is
rome against judea judea against rome
there is hitherto
been no greater event than this struggle
this question this deadly contradiction
and what's the struggle well there's
it's rome versus judea
but also judea versus rome each of them
has a view
of the other and here's here's how he
portrays it he says rome
felt the jew to be something like
anti-nature itself
it's antipodal monstrosity as it were in
rome the jews stood convicted of hatred
for the whole human race and rightly
provided one as a link
to right to link the salvation and
future of the human race with the
unconditional dominance
of aristocratic values roman values
right so the romans standing in for
for something much more global than
actual
rome which is good because if we say
this is the roman view no it wasn't this
is the review perhaps of some romans
but a lot of romans didn't take any
notice whatsoever of judea
as such or jewish culture and at the
same time
jews like so many other nationalities
spread throughout the roman empire and
lived their own you know uh part
particular lives within it
they were viewed as kind of weird in
that they didn't have idols
of god and they seemed to be you know
pretty troublesome not just to the
romans but the
greek successor states of the macedonian
empire before them
but i think that the most romans
wouldn't
have said that that was nietzsche was
accurately representing their view but
that's fine you know there's something
more going on here than
being historically accurate what about
the jewish view he says
um i'm not going to actually tell you
what the jewish view is we can just
recall the apocalypse of john
the most wanton of all literary
outbursts that vengefulness has
on its conscience so he's talking about
what we typically call the book of
revelations
uh the you know the apocalypse or
revelations of john of potmos
and you know that's a weird wacky book
of the bible i mean that is
you read the gospels and then you look
at revelations
and you're like these are two entirely
different kinds of literature
and reflect very different ways of
understanding
whatever christianity is supposed to be
and nietzsche is using it as an example
of
judaism right the jewish view of the
romans and he says here's what i want to
say the romans were the strong and noble
nobody stronger and noble nobler has
existed on earth or ever been dreamed of
that's debatable right every remnant of
them every inscription gives delight
if only one divines what it was that was
there at work the jews on the contrary
were the priestly nation of resentment
par excellence in whom they're dwelt in
unequal popular moral genius
one only has to compare similarly gifted
nations the chinese or germans
with the jews to sense which is of the
first in which of the
fifth rank so this is clearly
caricatures on
on both sides nietzsche is using this to
stand in for something else
does he really believe the stuff that
he's saying here that's a matter
i think of debate um we we probably do
want to
keep in mind and add to this the things
that nietzsche is saying about judaism
and christianity in chapters
7 8 and 15 of this he does point out
that there are these these christians
who he says dante made a blunder when he
said
placed above the gateway of hell the
inscription i too was created by
eternal love and then he talks about
thomas aquinas mentioning this and
tertullian dwelling on this
at great length tertullian really kind
of does represent a certain christian
type
who's in some respects uh very angry
and and i think you know you could say
it shows what nietzsche talks about is
resentment
i don't know that you can really tar
dante and
and aquinas with this but they are to
you know tertullian and aquinas do talk
about you know
the blessed in heaven getting to see the
sufferings of the damned and hell and
that being part of
what what's good about being in heaven
that does seem pretty resentment-filled
is that to be attributed to judaism well
only if you make the connection that
nietzsche
is making in uh chapters seven and eight
where he says okay judaism was really
this you know uh religion of hatred
against the powerful
again very debatable when we when we
turned actual jewish texts in history
and then christianity took that hatred
and transformed it into love which is a
seduction to another kind of
deeper hatred another kind of resentment
if you buy all that
okay well then you know you might go
along with nietzsche on this this
comparison
if you don't if you're dubious about it
then you have to figure out what you
want to do
with this this final set of uh
discussions
then he talks about who's won who's one
at present
and he again says well you know the
index of this is look at rome
right now you know who do we bow down to
uh the pope and the pope is you know the
representative
of this you know this jewish
point of view he says there can be no
doubt
um who do we bow down to three jews
and one jews jesus of nazareth the
fisherman peter
the rug weaver paul and the mother of
the aforementioned jesus named
mary rome has been defeated beyond all
doubt
and it's interesting that he needs to
stress how humble
peter and paul were you know that
they're part of the common people so
he's clearly
you know funneling the priestly
aristocratic and the commoner into
the this this thing that he's he's
amalgamating under
ju you know under judea right he also
talks about some historical developments
he tells us that the renaissance was a
time
where rome restored itself rome as being
this
you know focus of power of worldliness
of domination and so you know we could
think of
all the power plays that were going on
there and some of what we call the bad
popes
right and then you know that that falls
apart
and then we have the reformation and the
reformation which he associates
in particular with germany and
with with england kind of funny because
you know france was also
uh torn apart by the reformation as were
other places
as well but he says that's really a
restoration of this judea
motif and then we get the french
revolution
which he also views as the triumph
of this judea versus rome
dynamic we should actually see what he
says here
uh it triumphed over the classical idea
ideal and in this time
in an even more profound and decisive
sense the last political nobles in
europe
that of the french 17th and 18th century
collapsed before the popular instincts
of risontomont right
now how noble was the french nobility
wow that's you know that's a good
question to ask
there um and then he says that
in opposition to this we have a
restoration of
rome as well first before that we have
he says
in the midst of it there occurred the
most tremendous most unexpected thing
the ideal of antiquity stepped incarnate
in an unheard of splendor before the
eyes and conscience of mankind
and once again in opposition to the
mendacious slogan of verzantemon's
supreme rights of the majority
in opposition to the will to the
lowering the abasement the leveling and
the decline in twilight of mankind there
sounded stronger simpler and more
insistently than ever
the terrible and rapturous
counter-slogan supreme rights of the few
like a signpost to the other path
napoleon
appeared the most isolated and late born
man there has ever been
and in him the problem of the noble
ideal is such made flesh
we might ponder what kind of problem it
is napoleon this
synthesis of the inhuman and super human
right so he's identifying napoleon as
being not just a representative of rome
again but sort of like the superlative
representative and then i guess suppose
you could say that it was resontamont
that
drove all the other powers of europe
which were still aristocratic
to reign in napoleon and sentence you
know
to exile him twice and you know
again the story is a little bit too
simplistic and a little bit implausible
but that's
that's what nietzsche is presenting at
the end
of this first chapter to say that he's
bringing things to a conclusion about
this fundamental clash between
good versus bad and good versus evil
you